hi and welcome i'm anthony mason along
with Michelle Miller and we're here in
the CBS morning Taiyo to greenroom with
chef and food writer Sammy Nusrat who
didn't even consider a career in cooking
until she ate at Berkeley's legendary
Chez Panisse during college she got a
job as a food runner there and worked
her way up eventually impressing
renowned chef Alice Waters who's called
her this is big America's next great
cooking teacher I think Julia Child the
next great Julia Child was even put in
there but last year nas rads first
cookbook salt fat acid heat became a
best-seller and earned her a James Beard
Award at all that's a meal also inspired
it did a critically acclaimed Netflix
series by the same name the show
explores what nas Rack considers to be
the four vital elements of cooking you
guessed it the title of her book thank
you thank you for having me take us into
this because the first thing I thought
was wait what happened to sweet oh it's
true it's everyone's like what about
sweet and I do think sweetness is so
important certainly as humans we're
attracted to it yes but to me it's not
one of the crucial things in everything
that we eat these are the four that are
universal to all sweet things and salty
things so and I also think there's a way
where each of these four elements
interplays with sweetness and so you
know salty and sweet sour and sweet and
of course creamy and fatty and region so
and and I really love the idea of trying
to use cooking and use salt and
everything to bring out the natural
sugars especially out of things like
vegetables so if you know that when you
go to the farmers market and you're
buying the freshest vegetables they
actually have the highest amount of
natural sugar and then when you you know
roast broccoli in the oven and it gets
brown and caramelized it's not sweetness
that comes out so there's a way I think
where the more sort of familiar familiar
you are with cooking the more sweetness
you can bring out naturally without
adding sugar you weren't actually that
familiar with cooking when you started
at Chez Panisse nothing
grilled cheese sandwiches yeah so what
happened exactly and what was your aha
moment that led to this to this idea so
I I saved up for seven months with my
college boyfriend to eat at Chez Panisse
and his story this really incredible
experience I had never eaten in a fancy
restaurant like that before we were 19 I
was 19 and so we definitely stood out in
the fancy dining room and it was just
such an incredible experience and I felt
so cared for that immediately I wanted
to work there so I wrote a letter and
asked for a job bussing tables you can
delivered the letter yes i hand-deliver
it and very quickly I we know once I
started working there vacuuming the
floor and polishing so the well I start
you know you get to eat everything and
smell everything and watch the cooks
cooking and it was so inspiring and I
was a struggling poet in college that's
not good and so I was like oh I need a
skill and it was so inspiring so I
begged them to teach me how to cook and
the menu there changes every day so the
chef's don't use recipes because that
one day they're making paella the next
day they're making lasagna or Bolognese
or all different things from around the
world and so over time I was like how
are these people entering the kitchen
they don't set timers they don't really
check the temperature of the oven they
know how to make everything without a
recipe and I noticed these four elements
were basic to everything that we were
making so I came to one of the chefs and
I said oh I figured it out salt fat acid
Heat and he was like yeah I we all know
that duh okay and I said why isn't it in
any of the books you've told me to read
so at that time I was like I'm gonna
write a book about this one day and you
did and what's so interesting about this
book is how you illustrate I mean this
is really you're a cup of tea Anthony
because you're your stepdad was an
illustrator so I loved the fact that
this book is actually Illustrated it's
not photographs but why did you make
that decision well I I felt very
strongly that I loved beautiful food
photography but I felt like this book
the idea of my sort of theory here is
that once you know how to use these four
elements you can make anything taste
good
with or without a recipe and I didn't
want people to feel like they had to
rely on recipes and if you have spinach
in your house but my recipe calls for
chard you should know you can switch
those yes so if by doing overly styled
very beautiful photos it sort of sends a
message that you have to it should look
like it has to look like my stuff
doesn't even look like that so I worked
with this incredible illustrator Wendy
MacNaughton and she made look we made
all these amazing charts and things I
love them to show the ways that flavour
is the same around the world you know
and you tweak a few different things and
here you add like a different kind of
cheese to make your stuff taste maybe
you know Middle Eastern you use feta
cheese or you would use gorgonzola as a
source of acid for Italian food and
there's just a few basic things once you
learn them you can make anything taste
good what if I so unique about you is
that you're so different but because it
is so authentic it is not other you make
it so not being an outsider but you blew
up feeling that oh for sure I mean it's
funny cuz the more I think about this
and talk about it I'm like oh I felt
like such an outsider I'm like did
anyone really feel like an insider
that's part of it and also because I
always felt like I didn't belong I know
how hard that feels and I don't want to
ever make anyone else feel like that so
my I feel like flute is this incredible
tool to sort of bring everyone in and
I'm so lucky that I got to do that so
when did you get the idea of blending
your storytelling skills yeah if you're
with your food passion I've always
wanted to write since I was in high
school and I had an incredible high
school English teacher who really
encouraged me to be huge it was amazing
what teachers name
coach Dorman he was also my coach Thomas
Dorman thank you he lives now in
sedro-woolley Washington I was with him
the other day and and so I really went
to college sort of aiming to be a writer
yeah and then when I came to food its I
knew I didn't want to let go of writing
so I always pursued both yeah and I was
really lucky to get to find a way to
intertwine both and make a career out of
both and I can't really do just one
feel very much like both parts of my you
know my heart and my body need both my
mind would you say that your career has
really just skyrocketed since this
Netflix series that flicks is bananas
overnight it's really less than 1200
crazy
I'm FaceTime my girlfriend I know and so
I mean 190 countries simultaneously the
power of Netflix is beyond anything I
think anyone can understand yeah and so
I feel again really privileged to have
had this incredible okay no one asked
you because I read something about when
you were talking about developing this
series from your cookbook and you
described how you wanted in some ways
that kind of feel like your room at home
and all the quirky stuff that's there
it's actually a concept I've had myself
so I thought and most people looked at
me like I was nuts when we do our own
show here and what were you take me
through that process and what you were
thinking I can't take all the credit I
worked with an incredible team of my
producers and directors and really our
director Caroline sue she was I think so
charmed by my quirkiness well that she
really wanted to capture that and also
everyone at Netflix I think you know
from the moment that we met they were
they were like you're perfect just as
you are yes you're kind of imperfection
and silliness and the way you trip over
yourself and like you make huge mess
when you're cooking we don't want to
clean that up and make you perfect like
Martha Stewart or you know that exists
already but what doesn't exist is
somebody really accessible who also
knows their stuff and so they all
throughout the whole process really
encouraged me to just be myself which is
really funny because there's also a part
of myself that's like very immigrant
childlike perfectionist trying to like
tidy everything and clean everything so
we'd find ourselves in these rural homes
filming you know and I'd be like
organizing Michelle at somebody else's
house it should be like stop in Japan
Japan yeah how did you select the
location um I mean again it was a team
effort I feel like I've been in this
industry for a long time cooking so I
have had the incredible opportunity to
meet so many amazing people from around
the world so a big part
the connections were my personal
connections that we'd made over the
years and then you sort of you know you
you meet somebody and then you say oh do
you know someone who makes an amazing
soy sauce and so then they would send us
to the next person so it would my friend
Yuri was an incredible resource for us
our friend Nancy who chi-su was an
amazing resource for us in Japan and
then through them we got to meet all of
these amazing artisans and really I was
saying earlier that I started weeping in
the soy sauce factory I was so moved by
their like generations of tradition in
the place and I had asked I asked the
director I said why didn't you use that
footage of me crying it was so moving I
was so moved and she said you looked
like a crazy person
[Laughter]
did you find it a big leap to go from
you know working on the printed page and
in the kitchen to doing this all I think
you know it's been a series of jumps for
me first from the kitchen which is so
collaborative writing which is so sort
of on your own and solo and then back to
like another collaborative project of
making the show which in a lot of ways
TV production is a lot like working in a
restaurant where you it's a team effort
everyone you're only as strong as your
weakest persons you have to bring
everyone along you have to make do with
what you got you know and their time is
limited money is limited all that stuff
so that felt very familiar to me but
yeah there were all these people had
incredible strengths beyond what I knew
how to do so II got to learn a lot but I
you know for me story is at the heart of
everything and so I felt pretty
comfortable and also as I think in a lot
of ways as like I grew up to immigrant
parent with immigrant parents I grew up
not fitting in I've spent my whole life
learning how to make other people
comfortable yes and in some ways that's
hard for me because it squeezes my own
self often into a little corner but on
camera it's a great skill to have
because I can put anyone at ease and so
I felt really comfortable and I think it
made them feel comfortable and then we
made have very authentic scenes together
what is the means
next story oh my god you guys I
definitely need to rest so I'm gonna
take a break early next year and rest
and then I'm really looking forward to
writing and also I really have enjoyed
making this show so I look forward to
figuring out what show I get to make
what was the biggest surprise in that
process um I don't
oh my gosh that's a hard question but
there were a lot of surprises along the
way I think to me how fast it moves how
fast you just have to like get
everything done and you never get a
break and you just got we were running
for 40 weeks straight I had friends who
were like when can we hang out and I was
like pretend I'm pregnant and I call me
when the baby it just was non-stop
non-stop non-stop so I think that was
not something I was expecting hmm that
is it acid is it what's the last one
salt and he he he what's next I think
what I'll probably end up doing is what
I really look forward to doing with all
of this attention is using it to lift
other people up you know as a woman of
color in the food industry and now on TV
there are not a lot of us here and I've
already received so much attention for
that so much positivity which I'm so
grateful for but I woke up with like
kind of in a cold sweat a few weeks ago
like this is gonna get lonely if people
are like Oh some nina's are great hopes
I mean is the future so I feel like it's
now my responsibility to turn it and
bring others up alongside me did you
know did you have a hope when you did I
have a hope great hope as a person um oh
I have had many I mean Oprah yeah shall
Obama doing that yeah I mean I think any
strong women who I've been able to look
up to throughout the years have been
really a really inspiring to me so I
feel there and luckily they're
everywhere you know and a lot of them
aren't on TV a lot of them are just in
our family on the backs of restaurants
yeah I access restaurants hello can we
talk about that like that oh gosh you're
an inspiration and most importantly you
are such a jewel thank you so much to
Joy
such a delight I'm gonna break you I'm
gonna go I'm gonna get you to like
laughing tickle yes sameen Asura we bang
to you author and and superstar Congrats
on the series and the James Beard Award
everything thank you I'll be back
Lena Q all for watching thank you